[Música]
hola felicidades por completar la
formación inicial tus esfuerzos para
impulsar tu desarrollo profesional
nos inspiran a todos en khan academy y
ciertamente hacen de tu salón de clases
un entorno de aprendizaje transformador
la formación inicial ha concluido pero
recuerda que canacar me ofrece otros
recursos informativos y oportunidades de
educación continua entra al panel del
profesor y haz clic en la pestaña
recursos allí encontrarás materiales que
pueden ayudarte a usar khan academy con
tus estudiantes también puedes consultar
el centro de ayuda donde tendrás a tu
disposición una serie de artículos que
incluyen preguntas frecuentes y guías
para estudiantes profesores y padres de
familia recuerda también que puedes
reportar un problema de la plataforma y
recibir asistencia por parte de nuestro
equipo de soporte para más información
sobre las iniciativas de formación de
khan academy y otros proyectos sigue
atento a tu bandeja de entrada de correo
electrónico
siempre nos aseguraremos de que estés al
tanto de todo también puedes seguir
nuestro canal de youtube
khan academy en español en el que
encontrarás varias listas de
reproducción de formaciones anteriores
felicidades por completar la formación
inicial
[Música]